all right so the session that you're in
case you're wondering is called building
machine learning applications in Python
so what are you going to cover today
first I'm going to do some introductions
I'm Rashad after that you Chang is going
to take you through data engineering and
modeling an exercise where we'll need
that Yelp data set that I'm encouraging
you all to download and then afterwards
I'm gonna talk about deploying that so
really important
we're pacing this so everyone can follow
along so please follow follow along with
us use your laptop interrupt us raise
your hands if you've got questions or if
you're stuck this way one of us is
speaking the other one is available to
make sure that we get you on stock so
let's introduce ourselves first
I'm Rashad this is you Chang that's you
Chang we both work at dado we've both
been at data since the company was
formed you Chang's been with the project
for quite a while he's one of the
founders of the company he's our chief
architect now and a lot of his graduate
research at CMU is the underpinnings of
of our products at date oh by the way we
used to be called graphlab and I'll get
into that also I should let you know
that my backgrounds not machine learning
so all the machine learning questions
I'm going to redirect to you Chang but I
can talk about deployment so before
before we get get started into the into
things let's get a little sense of the
room so how many of you have heard of
dado before all right how about GraphLab
Oh more people yes so now you all know
that we're the same people on how many
of you our data scientists or identify
yourselves as data scientists got one
two three four okay that's awesome
how about data architects well we got
one two three oh nice data engineers yes
oh this is awesome
- each does oh yeah and so you Chang
mentioned there's another one yesterday
I didn't know about this Python ears
does anyone does anyone identify with
that
and what else there's a bunch of you
that didn't raise your hands so I want
to hear a little bit about what what do
you guys identify yourselves as what
what do you do say it again da novice
okay novice at what are we saying novice
at life novice at work what else
so novice at Python ISM is what I'm
guessing okay well that's we're gonna go
nice and slow with Python
so hopefully you won't feel that way by
the time our sessions over what else
anybody else analytic Acrobat analytic
Acrobat I like it I like it can you do
any actual like acrobatic things okay
well then then then it seems to fit
alright so again interrupt us raise your
hands let's make this interactive I know
it's late on a Friday and I know I'm
stopping you from getting to happy hour
or whatever you want to do after this so
uh but please let's let's make this fun
you had your hand raised what's going on
one more time I can try I was gonna give
you a demo of our company by showing you
some product stuff but fine we'll go
show you the download link okay
USB key to move around there we go okay
so let's do a quick demo or two about
what you can build using dedo I wanted I
had some slides about our platform and
all the products in it and I was gonna
show you all that but that's kind of
boring and I thought it'd be more fun to
show you some demos so this is only
gonna take a couple minutes so let's
make this big can you guys see this yeah
so a couple things to say before I get
started this is a demonstration
application so dedo builds a machine
learning platform we offer a machine
learning platform that enables you to
build predictive applications so I want
to show you a couple demonstrations of
predictive
apps you can build how many of you have
seen this demo already Oh only one
fantastic and that's Brian so it's
totally fun so what we've built here is
a very simple front-end application
that's deployed on Heroku that is a
recommendation system so let's do some
so we built this using the Amazon review
data set which if you guys are familiar
with it is thirty four million reviews
from 1996 to 2013 on books movies and
music so if we look up a book or a movie
Dumb and Dumber dull men look dumb and
dumber
I'll get recommendations for other
movies and like all good demos it
doesn't work the first time so I'm just
oh there we go so what's happening is we
get these recommendations so to do this
we've taken a train machine learning
model and deployed it as a service using
Dino predictive services so a cluster of
machines in AWS and then we're querying
that trained model with recommend with
input in this case dumb and Dumberer so
with dumb and Dumberer
which I actually haven't seen i'm
recommended Hollywood homicide hot
chicks I think that's right or the hot
chick scary movie 3 a lot of other
stupid comedies how about another
example you guys have a book or an album
I could keep going no that's too new
it's too new the TV oh that's ok the
album ok let's see see if I get
Californication there it is oh I have
seasons 1 through 3 I have the show in
fact ok let's see what I get
oh so now so I'm gonna get
recommendations for someone that likes
dumb and Dumberer and Californication so
I'm
getting a lot of the same movies but I'm
also getting some one hot minute
by the way blood sugar sex Magik these
are all albums by Red Hot Chili Peppers
so not too shabby so this is a really
simple recommendation app you guys have
all seen this you use a lot of products
today that that have that offer you
recommendations and so you can build
that sort of system with with dedos
platform really easily but let me show
you something that isn't that you don't
get to see all that much that you can
also build using our platform pretty
easily so let's say that I like dumb and
dumber not dumb and dumber and there it
is Dumb and Dumber on VHS good but my
wife wants me to read Sense and
Sensibility the book so what's it gonna
take for her to get me from watching
Dumb and Dumber to reading Sense and
Sensibility well here we see the the
shortest recommended path between the
two so first she has to watch Dumb and
Dumber with me then she'll get me to
watch happy gilmore which has Adam
Sandler it's also a dumb comedy but Adam
Sandler is a crossover artist so he does
some romantic comedies that leads you to
the wedding singer from that romantic
comedy we get to clueless which I don't
know if you guys know this or not but
clueless is a parody of Jane Austen's
Emma so that kind of makes sense that we
would move into Jane Austen land but I'm
not ready to read anything yet so I'm
gonna watch Emma an adaptation of the
book then I'm gonna watch another Jane
Austen's another book another movie
based on Jane Jane Austen book Mansfield
Park finally I'm ready to read something
so I read Mansfield Park and then I get
to Sense and Sensibility
so what makes this interesting is that
in order to generate the shortest path
we built a graph an item similarity
graph between the between all the items
in the data set and then given a
starting and ending point we found the
shortest path between them so obviously
this is a fun example of going between
two products but you could imagine this
is an upsell path or any sort of
activity where you're trying to predict
getting to a particular goal what are
the shortest steps in between so a great
example of something you can do with
learning that you know is a little bit
more than just recommending you a new
product so this is the first demo I
wanted to show you and then I wanted to
switch to a totally different
demonstration app so let's make this a
little smaller again the way this app is
architected is we have a three node
cluster running in AWS predicted using
data predictive services that's hosting
a trained machine learning model a deep
learning model or a neural net model
that's trained using the GPU for image
classification and then we have this
front-end app which is basically an HTML
page and a little JavaScript running on
Heroku and so we take the image and we
send it to the predictive service and
get back predicted labels so this model
was trained on the image net data set
which is a well-known data set for
object identification so let's see what
predictions we get so I don't actually
so common Newt so what you're seeing
here is you're seeing predictions the
predicted label of the item of the
object and a confidence score so from
the training set this was a common Newt
and so common Newt came out on top that
kind of makes sense let's try another
example so I've clicked on the image now
we send it to the service so let's look
at the predictions so black-footed
ferret you can barely see it in the
colors but there's a ferret here on this
data set that has no humans in it so
there's no human identification or a
person identification a lot of people
ask me why is there a dog in your logo
some of you might be asking that well
this is the answer this is our founder
Carlos's dog when the project started
back in 2009 and we were called graphlab
this is his Labrador and so when we get
predictions sure enough Labrador
Retriever is the the top prediction so
it's these are all images that we have
sort of in in our app but why don't we
search for something on Getty Images so
what do you guys want to search for that
Getty Images would have an image for
nothing say it again mantis shrimp is
that right
I have no idea what this looks like so
it's very cool all right so let's hope
that Getty Images has a has an image of
it live demos are so much fun because of
this little thing oh yeah that's right
everybody's getting yelled dataset at
this very moment which this is a great
time to ask is anyone need the USB key
should we pass them around no everyone's
got the dataset sweet I'm gonna refresh
the app we're gonna try that again
mantis shrimp here we go alright so
which one should I pick this one alright
let's see what we get
well this is pretty fun I've never seen
this one before spiny lobster I mean
it's not horrible considering it's an
unreleased in the seafood realm let's
see if we try a different picture what
we get so every time I'm clicking we're
sending the picture to this to this
model that's hosted as a service and
we're getting back the recommended
labels for the predicted labels well
that one turned out worse so here we go
two quick examples of applications that
you can build really easily using data
as platform so far so good guys question
yeah go ahead okay so the question was
is this performing deep video indexing
or is it using metadata search this is
extracting features from the image
itself so not video image using the
image but training a neural net
classifier to extract features from the
images themselves alright and so before
we get on to the to the meat of today's
tutorial we should put a plug in for the
other times at PI data that you can come
and hear us talk so tomorrow I'll be
talking about scikit-learn models in
production which is a talk focused on
deployment and then on Sunday you guys
can get a deep dive into the scaleable
out of core data structure called the s
frame you Chang is going to talk about
that which we built specifically for
machine learning
all right so not everybody's
participating yet but hopefully you guys
will be I'm gonna step over you Chang's
gonna take over and we're gonna do an
intro to data science and ml and
remember raise your hands or interrupt
us if you've got questions thanks we
haven't even started yet don't clap it's
not over okay
everyone hear me yes good okay so I'm
gonna do a quick introduction to kind of
data science data science and machine
learning I I was told to target this at
a rather introductory level and so
that's what I have done so I'm going to
explain interesting concepts with no
math whatsoever so let's see how well
did how well we do there so these are
links if you do not like he is the the
first data set up I did Adele is 2015
data does if that contains a Yelp data
set so we would like to try use as much
as possible real data so that it's a set
of about eighty four megabytes compress
this Jason so Jason has a lot of blank
space in it so it unzips to I think
something about 300 megabytes and then
there's he talks not zip which contains
the PowerPoint slides as well as the
ipython notebooks there is I will go
mainly go through the data engineering
ipython notebook okay there are a few
other exercises and things which you can
get the data from from the from the very
last very last link that exercises is
much bigger it's about 300 megabytes
contains a subset of stack overflow 300
megabytes a stack overflow and that goes
through a number of kind of like s frame
data engineering exercises okay so
this thing about a little about what
does a typical kind of data size process
looks like we you can't begin with raw
data your data has come in in a various
sources
yes ve sequel and so on and then the
first thing that's really important to
do is to try to cut it in the two before
you leave you either doing have learning
and machine learning you do not want to
have you want to get a good a set of
data which you did not train on
otherwise you can discover over your
over your over feed on that you don't
get a good sense of how well your data
will work in the real and real world so
the first is valve engine split you can
train set and the validation set you
will perform machine learning modeling
on the training set you evaluate using
the validation set and then that tells
you something about model that has
something about the data you go back and
you tune the data again right and that's
kind of essentially the basic outline of
what we do here data cleaning
exploration modeling model
interpretation and result interpretation
so the first key to more data to data
cleaning is to know your tools there are
many there are sources generally you
need multiple tools your data might live
on Hadoop may live on hive maybe you may
have the excessive our sequel by a spark
know your tools well because and of
course you in contact have less
structure formats like CSVs and CSVs are
annoying because there's no kind of
everyone writes them a little
differently right so can know your power
options here's a here's a fun question
what's your favorite CSV delimiter it's
got CSV but people used tabs who use
other stuff comma yeah by commas are
knowing you have to escape dams and
shrinks sometimes this is the very
fascinating one I've encountered once
the bike Oh X F F or 255 this H s
slightly clever because there's actually
fully compatible utf-8 strings you do
not need to quote it or escape anyway
because o x FF is not actually legal
utf-8 it's kind of entertaining but
yes so there are all kinds of soap and a
CSV parser has a huge number of options
you have if you ever encounter this
interesting CSV files explore them where
our s frame also has a good number with
with interesting capabilities right
there nothing which is really important
to do is okay
pay attention to missing values there
can be many especially when you get data
from other sources from other people
from other teams they gave many
representives for missing value either
come from every your data comes from our
Nan's are common the string n a is also
common Python has nuns and so on so
forth right I've seen I have had seen
data says in which missing values are
represented by negative 9 9 9 and that's
slightly annoying
I have like you want to be able to
visualize your data understand the
visualization tools MATLAB is great
bouquet is great and you you want to be
able to just explore the data in
whatever way you can
so the key demo which I'll go through
here is to predict whether a yelp review
is funny or not
so here are two reviews the left one
says rosy Dakota and I love Shepherd dog
park is a very convenient around by lots
of parts there's a xeriscape baseball
fields both houses etc the right line
says the oldest man who owns the stores
as sweet as can be pressed sweeter than
cookies or ice cream here's a lowdown
giant ice cream cookie sandwiches for
super cheap the flavor permutations are
basically endless and so on which is
funny which is not left or right well
yeah so the left is not funny the right
is funny it's kind of not so easy to
tell what what makes something funny or
what makes something not funny and this
is kind of what we're going to go
through today so the tools were used
here for the exploration is really we're
going to use kind of pieces of craft
I'll create so we have this data
structure we have is called an S frame
you can think about something a pandas
dataframe
it has it has very similar looking
functions
API is slightly different but it's
substantially more scalable risk will
scale to disgrace together SSD we go we
go out of core the internal back-end
storage is heavily optimized column
compressed column store as frames
herself is soon be part of an open
source package it's technically open
source now but you can't read it's not
so easy to put to make pie pie or call
application of it but we are working
we're we're factoring it to make it an
actual Python package and we also canvas
which is a data visualization tool which
is part graph type created ok so I
discovered this fascinating plug into
Jupiter recently so forgive the
swooshing ok we're kin so we're going to
do visualization so the first thing is
we're gives me a lip in various places
so we're going format whole new okay try
that
suus okay it's a empower graph that okay
so the first thing we have is a CSV is a
CSV parser
okay we have a VCS we it is as fast if
not faster than dependency parser but
here's some more fast really fascinating
type inference capabilities so for
instance we're get it look at it Yelp
data set the yup dataset is is a JSON
file okay so each line is a JSON string
mrs. ID and so on so forth if I as a
JSON string now you can we can think
about this as a CSV file of one column
where each column where each row
contains a dictionary and we can parse
that so we infer that the column
tightness is a dictionary and now we can
look at it so this is the business s
frame as type is dictionary we can slice
it we can pull out any any any arbitrary
value we can arbitrarily slice it range
20 to 40 so and so forth okay now one of
our interesting capabilities ability to
unpack a column so we can unpack the
column x1 and that pulls apart the
contents of the that post-american
tensor dictionary and now we end up with
a big table which is all the information
business ID category city address
latitude and so on and so forth we have
some built in data exploration
capabilities we can run it so and that
gives you a quick visualization of all
the data so business ID categories with
one glassing as you got restaurants are
the most common category
in the entire table city address that if
you don't it you name and so on so a
subway is the most common restaurant
and yeah so a lot of these statistics
are done carefully with one pass that
one pass so kind of like the number of
unique values it's an estimate so all
these are done by one pass catching
algorithms so we can run them on very
large data sets very efficiently
so we can also look at the table view
and you get to see I tell the excel is a
very powerful tool so the ability to
just quickly scan through all the data
so this this works even if the dust has
really big what happens is that we as
you scroll we page in different sets
different rows of the table okay so next
we get a lot of review data the reveal a
that looks similar so with the new
version a Python notebook the
incremental printing since we're stopped
working but that's fine
so if it looks the same it's just one
big JSON glob we can we'll just unpack
it directly since we know what it is and
the reviews so it just looks like this
we have a business column we have a date
column review ID stars text and so on
and so forth right and what and you see
fine that okay essentially we so this is
one row of the ice-cream business ID
date we can do weather d-type so the
estrogens are strongly typed so each
column must be one of five string
integer float diction always about
dictionary and lists which are arbitrary
recursive so there's allows us to hold
arbitrary Jason Jason information will
inside one cell and as well as an image
type which which we use for cat the deep
learning applications now so one thing
we see is that votes is their dictionary
that's a dictum there
fire we look at reviews zero votes this
guy's here dictionary so votes as cool
funny and useful so we're gonna do funny
prediction so we do need a funny the
funny column so if further unpack the
funny the votes column
and now we have okay
there now we have cool funny and useful
okay so now so with the whole cable is
called an F scream but then what what
makes this different from some of the
other scalable data frame structures out
there is that it doesn't quite just
express a table and this it's not
exactly it's not a sequel wrapper or
some sort really it the S the S frame
looks like a data frame and they have a
column type color s array which looks
like an umpire array so for instance
here we can pull out one column funny
votes okay there's a total number of
funny votes so funny pose here is an S
array and we can take kind of the fact
the funny column the cool column and
useful column add them together and
assigned it and create a new column and
reviews called total votes and if we
look at reviews now contract okay there
we go there's a new column in their
total votes because we cut we maintain
our materialization format so we are
we're actually creating these columns in
memory on this we we will use memory
until we have to go to this there's a
there's a caching there's an extensive
caching layer in place okay now I'm
gonna go back to slides
where are my sights
okay so we're gonna look at a PCA here
that's something that first - yeah we're
gonna use scikit-learn
okay now mathematically they say a PCA
base it finds the principal eigenvectors
of the data covariance matrix now what
the hell does that mean so let's do it
once more
somewhat into it some are more
intuitively first I'm going to normalize
the data so the center of all the data I
mean about it dies at 0 0 we're going to
find a line passing through the center
so that the average distance of every
data point is minimized ooh there we go
this is the first principal component
that's it to get a second principal
component we find the second line which
are right angles the first line so that
the average distance to every data point
to the line is minimized and that's the
second principal component to get the
principal component you find the
headline there's every angle so all the
previous lines and so the average
distance to it every day our points
minimize again now obviously there's no
more such lines because this data is 2
dimensions so this is care first there
can be only be as many principal
components as they are dimensionality of
the data ok so let's take a quick demo
okay so we're gonna use my pilot and
scikit-learn here okay so we got imports
I could import pca from scikit-learn
okay now we're gonna just look at funny
cool and useful these three columns
cover that or data confident or pandas
dataframe so they're comparing a
sprinter pilots airframe I guess slice
out three columns funny cool and useful
I grab PCA on that so PCA create us for
three components and there are fit of
our fit on the data it rises quickly and
this other this is the output
it's our collection numbers now
let's see we employed this thing okay
some mepod live incantations so you can
take a closer look if you want but this
is what the data looks like okay so here
are all the data points there's a blue
dots the red line is a principal
component this is the main line in which
most of the variation of the data occurs
occurs in and then there are also two
other lines which are hard to see
there's a green line and there's a blue
line here which are gathered every two
two remaining access of the data okay
now what can we do with it now really
the objective here we want this will be
a chart interpret this thing right what
does this actually mean right okay let's
do a slightly bigger fit wagger fit
funny cool useful end stars okay and
where girl rap is here on this okay now
let's see how so we just get numbers
here but essentially they are in the
order funny cool useful and stars okay
now we have weights here there's a first
creampuff principal component has weight
77% right and and these are components
for funny cool useful stars what this
means is that the prints the primary
components is that most of the variation
of data can be explained by reviews
which are both of which are all funny
cool and useful but has absolutely
nothing to do with stars so in other
words most of the time most of the time
funny cool and useful like I've
correlated with each other but the
amount of those of us do not tell you
anything about the stars
okay am I the second component we look
at values it says it explains that 11%
of the variation of data say it's a
funny reviews I and D correlated with
cool and also and D correlated with
stars there's something ok yeah so but
kind of I'll just by looking at the
weights of the components that helps you
a lot of information about that gives
you some information about what the data
sort of looks like why the common common
patterns you see where the data set but
we can do
but we can do it we can but they see
there's more more capabilities to for
pca right so this got a quick summary
the whale combo says how strongly the
data varies along the component and come
on sorted by weight but what PCA also
gets you is damage sanity reduction
right and this is one of the most
important aspects of PCA so normally
what I do is I get a number of
components is much smaller than a number
of dimensions and data so for instance
here I have a 2008 up so maybe I just
pick one dimension okay how do I achieve
that my favorite dachshund everything
that's essentially my data is begins a
much higher dimension I'm going to try
to bring it down to something much
smaller right maybe I got used in in
some other play with a patient's I can
use it other machinery applications like
a user of visualization and so on okay
now to do this we project each data
point onto the set of components and
really we're only gonna maintain the
distances along each component along
each component direction right and you
see what this really is this value is
the inner product between data point and
the component vector right and what this
really does is wag a project and we go
rotate the data so now now this is only
a one x axis here and my data point only
lives along this x axis okay now where
is this use Y the one one of the most
common applications of this is something
called eigenfaces in eigenfaces what
happens is that each axis is a pixel so
I have as many axis as I as I have the
size of image each data point is a face
image so my data has number of pixel
width has llama pixel height worth of
dimensions and mine um and I guess I'd
like a number of components which is
much much smaller than our pixels maybe
20 right and you end up with faces with
components which look like that right
and this is one of the simplest face
recognition methods well what happens is
you take you take faces you project the
faces onto a come onto these components
and you compute au which are now much
smaller you're not looking at
maybe 128 about hundred pixels I'm only
looking at a sort of vector of maybe a
hundred maybe 100 near double values
right
and we'll compute new my nearest
neighbor within this components
component space right and this is called
eigenfaces and I think it's 1980 1987
and one of the first with a really
effective face recognition models okay
but so next we gotta look at about
actually get to solving that funny
problem okay next is again modeling
machine hangs all by modeling what is
the model a model is x-ray we had this
really fascinating debate in office once
about what defines the model right the
physicists have a different understand
why model is machine have a different
say my mother is but essentially a model
is extremely simplified view of the data
right and the key is that all models are
wrong but some are useful right now one
of the most common models
well simplest yet most powerful things
are linear classifiers and this is what
I do here logistic regression one
logistic regression is it does two
binary classification and there are
generalizations do the multi multiple
classes but let's just talk about binary
classification
right and so here's an example I have
two reviews here one funny and why not
one is not you have different than most
- one star and usefulness score of four
the other has five stars and usefulness
score - okay what is my model say I run
loss your suggestion on it and we end up
a model that looks like that we have a
constant value there's always a constant
value we have stars as weight negative
three and useful weight one now what
makes this a regression linear model is
okay how do I classify for say the first
data point I take the constant value I
added two stars one times negative three
which is the weight I think useful for
multiply it by the weight one and look
at the output so that's greater than 0
so that's funny
that's one let's cut the pasta that
costs substituting the values for a
second using something with just less
than zero and this is a negative cost
and it's not funny that's it that's not
just a regression there's a less linear
modeling right logistic regression
defines as well as support vector
machines and a hole a very very large
collision more those all fall under this
basic class the key difference is how
much do you weigh examples which are
which are almost wrong or which are
wrong which are just wrong how much how
much do you weigh examples which are
classified incorrect by the model how
much you penalize them in different ways
and there's a loss function and the
difference being all the linear models
is simply the choice of loss function
right and so what do I do if I get
categorical variables when it says day
of the month or maybe this review
contains the word bread right so what
happens is that I'm expanding my mate
I'm expanding my data quite a lot right
so every every data point will have a
value for J equals 1 days 2 there goes 3
and is 0 if it's not true and if 1 it is
true right it's a general one feature of
a category and now this can get this
would become a very very big very large
data set and normally is represented
sparsely so I only store the ones so
there's no may represent a sparse matrix
right so now what we gonna do here
really was a use Carla create for some
of the machine learning pieces for the
actual learning why because most machine
packages require to carefully transform
the input into a purpose shapes like for
instance because transferring the sparse
matrix to feed it and write this can
make later interpretation quite
difficult especially when to reverse it
reverse the process take the
coefficients and go reverse it and
figure a figure out what figure out what
they mean
I have no cell to work on the pipeline
to actually get the data in right so
what our toolkits
the basic idea is that we take the S
range directly as input you give us
shrinks you give dictionaries you give
us sparse or dense data we
try come do something sensible with it
so strings up automatically interpreting
categories and the output coefficients
will reflect that where if are
interpretable dictionaries Cantabria
sparse factors and output and the result
coefficients are interpretable and the
other key is that we design it because s
frames go out of core right we can hold
hundreds of gigabytes on the sail on a
laptop essentially and so all the
algorithms are built to use out of the
core data right and they're very robust
and automatic solver selections and so
on right and so this is the key part the
demo with using the update asset to
predict whether review is funny or not
okay sounds good so predicting funniness
okay first thing that we will see is
that really many many things have no
votes many other reviews have no votes
whatsoever right not not funny not
really not funny not useful nor cool
right and we I got throw that away right
and while Gator is a reviews square
bracket reviews of total votes this is
what we call a logical filter right and
well it was a logical filter let's go
filter it selects all rules for which
the inner predicate the corresponding
row in the inner predicate says non
empty non zero right so we can do more
interesting stuff like reviews give me
all reviews which are where the funny
boy is less than 10 and all the useful
books are greater than 5 for instance
right and ok we can run that and give
some output yeah okay right and so a lot
a lot of what we do is lazy evaluated so
finds that you see here we do not
actually know the number of rows you can
materialize that late that way if you
want to right so I got the
classification of funny right so the
first thing I do is that reviews with at
least one vote for funny are funny
so the here Ragab I know I sit so
reviews funny equals the reviews funny
greater than zero right so they're just
fine arises binarize as the data living
us with funny of all just zeros or ones
okay so is it the data is integer by the
contents are all zeros or ones so we we
compress it very efficiently back end so
you don't have to worry about that hey
it takes out 64 bits no it will end up
picking up one bit so the first thing we
do always is okay let's make a train
validation split train validation equal
reviews the random split spare 0.9 so
90% of our stop are going to the
training data and 10% we're going to
validation set
okay now let's actually do something
first thing you ever always do is let's
get a baseline right with our baseline
there is you do not know if what you do
is actually making an improvement at all
right so here we're going to count the
number of funny votes that the count a
number of things which are not funny and
kind other things which are funny in the
validation set and the first thing is
okay fifty three point seven six percent
of things are not funny so if I just
predict everything it's not funny
that gives us fifty three point eight
percent accuracy okay so the objective
is now to do better than this okay now
so you will see this in the notebook as
well - I try to make it so that every
section is executable on its own so
everyone will repeat this function
select features over and over again but
just get they get bigger and bigger I
will add as we add more and more
features into the model right so the
first is okay let's add the let's try to
predict funny from stars so we're gonna
just select features we are just select
the stars column and the funny column
because we actually need that to Train
perform a select features from other to
get the modified Trinette validation
split and we do not just take classifier
create
train right now a train data we are
going to classify the funny column and
we tell it a validation set okay
this runs well in incidentally we do we
do we do and we do automatic solver
section and background so because this
is really small we an are just using
Newton method and converges really
really quickly okay so one thing we can
look at media leaves the coefficients so
stars the intercept zero point three
four stars negative weighted that means
that stars predicts funny is nt quarter
funny essentially the higher than the
higher the stars the number of stars the
less funny this of the funny funny
things have low stars right South a nail
car
before you this actually has been
observed before elsewhere before okay we
can add date time as a feature this
takes a little bit more work but
essentially the first thing we're gonna
do here is we're gonna take the date
column and interpret it as a date time
type so we're the column type which is
called date time right and we can split
it up into a year month day we cut it up
we cut out the day time components year
month day and interpreter strings
because normally interpretation service
integers will mean that will mean that
the weight gets multiplied by the value
of the month which is like twelve or one
and you do not want that you wind the
you want a year you and a month you want
day to be interpreted categorically
right and so I do here is simple we
interpret as a string right you can
operate a string and we just run it as
normal okay once again that runs quickly
and we can do any coefficients so the
end of the year is funniest okay
people write funny reviews towards the
end of the year December
date night December November October or
a positive correlate very funny okay
that's interesting but let's see how far
we can go but oh yeah also you see now
that our validation accuracy is now
about 60% oh no it's a roll over to the
other side so 60 zero point six is
everyone 6 zero seven one so about 60%
so that's an improvement from the
baseline of about fifty three point
eight percent right okay it's time
improvement let's go further let's see
how far we can go okay at business
categories as a feature right so maybe
certain business categories are more a
funnier than others okay
and this actually gets quite
entertaining so business first the
business s frame as business idea and
categories in it okay the category is a
counter and professors
it's a list it's a list of stuff right
now we're going to do is that we want to
join it against the reviews frame okay
but that we also want to interpret the
categorical categories as a spouse
vector right so we wanted to go so this
business has music and DVDs that has
value one books has value one magazines
has value one and everything else is
zero and we don't care about it right so
this guy automating the princess
sparsely so the first thing is okay
we're good use a big business category
and use a lambda you apply a lambda
expression essentially to convert it to
care for every element key : one right
so for the least element has value one
so if we run this
you see now categories is now
accountants : one bikes : one shopping :
one and so on right okay and then to
make it to join it back against the my I
think we're just gonna join it back
against my review information right so
here is kind of business categories
we're just join it back against business
to get categories and so we take the we
take the review says frame we join it
against business ID and categories right
side thing just beside the case we don't
care about all the remaining fields
we're join it on the field business ID
and the left joint okay
we run this this is a little bit longer
because hardly do the lazy evaluation
and now our accuracy very accurate
seekers are 61% so badly shakers is
about 61.6% when the accuracy one six
61.7%
okay so let's you'll fine let's look at
how well we do oh that's the way the
coefficients okay
the funniest categories is personal
injury law and public relations as well
as the borage retesting yeah adult
entertainment some where they're the
least funniest categories our session
photography and shaved ice and shared
office spaces recording studios
neurologists act for aquariums Argentina
I don't know why is what is the business
category Argentine okay yeah so yeah
this kind of again just model
interpretation right now last thing
we're gonna do here is again a tax as a
feature okay so here is simple where
everything is the same what I do is that
we are just going to take the tax of the
review positive through one that's a
simple simple utility libraries we have
in a text an ethics to account words
right and that just takes for the text
just that extracts takes a returns a
dictionary which is for each word how
many times they do occur and so on okay
this is a little longer to run probably
about that it twenty twenty days against
also I'm not gonna wait for it but here
this is what the output looks like okay
now this is interesting so our training
accuracy went up to about eighty two
percent a validation accuracy is only
about sixty three percent right this
starts to smell of essentially
overfitting so the reason is there are
now because now you have one coefficient
for every word right so we have only
about hundred thirty thousand examples
but we have ninety-eight thousand ninety
nine thousand coefficients right and so
let's go over fitting essentially what
happens is that your model is becoming
really really good at predicting the
training data but not so good at reading
things which are outside of the training
data right so we can add a lot of these
can be tuned very carefully you can tune
the regularization get the other stuff
but the alternative is
let's just trim out some words okay so
we can reduce the number of coefficients
by kind of throwing away some uses uses
features now you may have heard you have
idea if you're my first stop word
removal these are things that these are
things we have but then we're gonna just
do something something simpler which is
because a one-hole encoder essentially
always oh it does is that we interpret a
week we take we take the text with a
text column and we drop all category all
categorical variables which occur
infrequently leaving only a top 5,000
right so where the wahad normally I said
what really what it does is it it takes
it is categorical it takes a column of
categories right and split up into an
array so there's 1 1 in the array
essentially exactly what we did earlier
to get to get a sparse array to get a
sparse matrix from categorical input it
does exactly that but then what we can
do as well is that this has a capability
of dropping dropping infrequent features
right and we can see what it does so
aha I didn't run something earlier okay
but essentially this look have a nice
presentation software but the problem is
it's hard to go back and forth but
essentially what happened what it does
is a adds a column called encoded
features which are now just just a
dictionary of numeric IDs numeric IDs to
value numeric ID so value okay you can
you can run you can run this on your
notebook and we can train the classifier
based on that so now we have much fewer
coefficients there's only five thousand
five thousand coefficients one hundred
thirty thousand examples that's good and
we look through the end training
accuracy 68 percent validation accuracy
sixty-six percent okay so that's good so
now we have gone from about fifty three
percent accuracy from the SR baseline up
to now about 66 percent okay since the
encoder provençe time remapping it
remembers things to numeric categories
it's a bit more where their share
coefficients but then we get that these
are the worst most predictive of not
funny rental 2011 group on high right
but then what are interesting are the
things which are most predictive of
funny I'm not going to run this because
it's being recorded you can look at it
yourself
essentially the worst most pretty funny
are all swear words yeah so the last
thing we can do now is we can add user
ideas a feature what this is essentially
the Chiefs is personalization so ideas
you know some users are funnier than
others right
so very simple we just kind of just add
user ID to the selection here right and
then we end up with 72% validation
accuracy okay so this our final so it's
answer we went from 50 53 percent all
throughout the 70% gradually adding one
feature at the time right finally
personalization at as the most as a most
boost to our accuracy
just for fun
what happens if I try to just predict
whether review is funny or not just from
the user ID okay we're never 70 percent
right so just user ID alone gives us 70
percent accuracy
okay what does that mean why okay
why any thoughts yeah
okay so is there some reviewers some
some reviewers like inherently some
people are very funnier than others and
some people here I post funnier abusing
others okay that's one
funny people write funny reviews okay
and I possibly there's a strong
correlation between person and vocab
choice so text and user ID may
practically make me overlap significant
B however there's another way to think
about this this is something which is
really important thing about when doing
feature engineering which is your choice
of features may have performance
implications beyond your metric of
choice which is in this case is how
accurate the prediction is right so if
we look at the whole review a crazy
sorry this should be 72% here so if we
look at just under review accuracy user
ID alone guess any 2% adding all
features wit user ID gives me 72 percent
okay but if I lower accuracy per
reviewer kind of like group it together
and look at just accurate aggregated
accuracy per reviewer we get a much
bigger difference here see seven percent
versus almost seventy percent right and
this is a quick plot a plot of what is
the accuracy gained by using all the
features for reviewers with less than a
certain number reviews there's hard to
read but what this means is okay for
reviewers with less with less than ten
reviews over here by adding all by
having all the features we get a much
bigger boost in accuracy right this
makes a lot of sense because for
reviewers with reviewers which have only
one review for instance right we're
gonna make one review you have know if
very little information about how funny
the person is right and that and so
adding all the remaining features gives
us a large boost in accuracy and so this
is the last key I'd last thing which is
essentially going beyond a little beyond
just the metric which you are looking at
which when doing feature engineering
have no your to a true real objectives
getting high IQ
see alone is not enough you need to know
something about how the model is
intended to be use for instance in this
case the reality is probably you are is
SEL product very likely you have a lot a
lot of really users with only one or two
reviews and therefore a model which use
an ID alone user ID alone for prediction
will necessarily do very poorly on all
these users right so this is in part a
question of your data set where do you
get at mm how do you how do you obtain
the I said it's also a question of
there's a cleaning because when doing
training we're doing model training
frequently you want to you may want to
throw away some of these users because
they tell you so little information
there isn't better not to have them and
all when doing the training in the first
place but then that also biases you up
there so biases your model in some cases
especially when you're doing feature
engineering so this is something to you
wants a constant keep in mind off your
your a simple accuracy score may not be
fully predictive of how it is going to
be like in the real world which is why
I'm a be testing is important to right
so that's essentially all I have so
cover - frame talk on Sunday at 10 a.m.
and we will talk about how we make a
stream and s-cross skill to essentially
terabytes of data on a single machine
right and then now ratchet will come and
give us a talk how do we deploy this
thing into production so who's still
who's who's having trouble with GraphLab
create show of hands who's alright thank
you for sticking with us for this long
so you Chang if you can help some folks
out so a couple things so I forgot to
mention this up front I should have
we're a Python package Python - so folks
the running Python 3 I apologize we
don't have anything for you yet so yes
so keep an eye out for you Chang and as
you see them sort of bounce up raise
your hand or
interrupt me definitely want to make
sure everybody's running GraphLab create
before today's over okay I already
showed you that so you guys so you Chang
just walked through how to how to train
a machine learning model using this Yelp
data set so I'm not going to go through
all of that but just to set some context
here I'm running c-can I go full screen
it's just gonna do the right thing all
right I'm running graphlab create
version 1.3 this is an eye Python
notebook and I've gone through the same
basic steps that you Cheng went through
so you can see I looked I loaded the
same data set that you guys all have so
what I'm gonna cover for this last part
of the tutorial you guys are almost
there
almost at the end of the first day is
how do you deploy this model as a
service now and go ahead do you have a
question
aha sorry good good question
so this is a this is called data
engineering deployment is the name of
the notebook you should see it oh no
interesting so are you running ipython
notebook or Jupiter aha so the so I
think I may have understood what the
issue was that someone else was having
to I wrote this notebook and we wrote
these notebooks using Jupiter so the
latest version of ipython notebook so
its uses a new format or a new version
of the format so I don't think it'll
work with ipython notebook but shoot me
an email and I'll send you an old like a
translated version for ipython notebook
the previous version how many people are
stuck with that
it tanked ipython wall I did not think
it had that much power no no we can work
around it today yeah so what so the
issue that you Chang went through really
fast there is on the latest version of
anaconda it depends on a very recent
version of the tornado web server which
graphlab create also depends on but we
depend on an older version of it and
we're both kind of stuck in a Python
package in maturity all the things that
Conda solves for you but since we don't
have a condo package yet you can't take
advantage of so the workaround is if
you're stuck when you try to pip install
GraphLab create and saw an error that in
incorrect version of tornado the
workaround is to install the the
specific command and I'll write it up
here just so that everybody can see it
do it right here
it's pip install tornado equals equals
4.1 so we're basically going to force
pip to install this version of tornado
and then graph up create should be fine
now if GraphLab creates not fine then
the workaround that'll work is you first
uninstall GraphLab create this is gonna
sound amazing guys you're gonna love
this
then you uninstall tornado then you
install GraphLab create and then you
install this version of tornado because
GraphLab create depends on an older
version of tornado so there's this
chicken and egg sort of problem okay
remember to keep keep interrupting me
with questions the goal of this session
is to show how easy it is to kind of
take what we've built so far what we've
trained so far and make it consumable by
others so to deploy it into a production
like environment okay
alright so so this is very similar to
what you chang did so i'm not going to
go through all of this but i'm doing the
same sort of operations on that s frame
I'm creating a we're going to do a
classification if something is funny or
not so it's exactly the same thing that
happened before and so we're actually
going to get to the model training step
and then one difference is that I'm
training only on the text features and
you check talked about that but the way
that I've trained this model is only on
the text feature is using a logistic
regression model
so right now I've gotten a model and
let's I can show you so this is my
trained model you guys can follow along
using the the data engineering
deployment notebook there's subtle
differences in this one which is why
this one's called data engineering
deployment live because it's got my AWS
credentials in it and I didn't want to
give those to you so and that's what
we're gonna do next the next thing we
want to do is deploy this model as a
service to a cluster of machines in AWS
and then query that service so we're
gonna do that together so far so good
no one has interrupted me yet all right
okay that's fine I'll take your smiles
instead of your questions so first
things first let's write the function or
the service API so we're we're deploying
this model as a service so let's decide
how we want that service to respond
what's the interface for the web service
so in the old days this might be a wizz
document if we're gonna write awful web
services with XML and just awfulness but
now it can be a lot simpler where we're
communicating using JSON and we're just
writing a Python function so here we go
we've written we've got a function we're
gonna call it the funny predictor
function it takes in text so any string
we're going to take that text we're
going to do the same feature engineering
or feature selection that we did when we
trained the the machine learning model
and then we're going to call that same
model that same model that you guys
trained that we were just looking at
here we're going to to transform the
data after we selected the features out
of the data we're going to transform the
data and call the classify method to get
back a
classification about whether we predict
that this text is funny or not so what
you can imagine is we've taken this
train model and now we want to deploy it
as a service so what's the action what
are the what's the thing we're trying to
do we want to send in a review as a
string of text and sit and have the
model returned funny or not right so
this is our function instead of just
returning if the class is is equal to
zero then we're gonna say it's not funny
I thought we should add a funny column
so that way we get back something that's
a little bit more human readable so I'm
gonna run this and now I'm gonna try
funny predictor just this function
that's sitting in my ipython notebook
damn this is good so from the model we
trained we got back the prediction with
50 to 53 percent probability that damn
this is good is funny
what do you guys think okay so now we've
got the function so now let's let's do
the let's set up the cluster let's set
up the deployment let's set up the the
predictive service so you set up your
AWS credentials these are not my AWS
credentials but mine are already in my
session and then to use to use ec2 as
our environment we need to set up a
little bit of configuration and this
doesn't render really well see if I can
can you guys still read that that looks
so much better can you guys read that is
that okay
so what we're what we're doing and I'm
up here what we're doing here is we need
to set up some configuration parameters
for how we want to use ec2 and if you've
done a lot of stuff in AWS like I have
this gets kind of annoying to have to
specify the instance type the region
over and over again your credentials
where you want to store logs so we have
this convenience object that we call the
environment and so we instantiate one of
those we give it a name so that way we
can refer to it oh I can't double-click
so we give it a name which we indicate
where an s3 one is store logs for
anything we're doing in ec2 we want the
logs to go to some durable place the
instances go away we lose the logs so we
patent we provide a place in s3 for the
logs what region we're gonna launch this
in Oregon
what instance type so m3x large pretty
standard and then for a clustered
environment the number of nodes so
that's what num hosts is so I want a
three node cluster feel free to make
this as big as you want but you're gonna
pay for those instances so keep that in
mind
for this example you don't need a three
node cluster one node is just just fine
so I've already got this environment
I've already created it so I'm just
gonna load it and see I'm loading it
using the if you guys remember from
earlier today the get adder or if you
have if you've used that in Python
before so I'm referring to it by its
logical name and I'm printing it out and
you can see uh-oh I am leaking my access
key to you guys okay good
if you want to see all the environments
I have you can do that - it's just
graphlab dot deployed out environments
so one of the things that makes this a
little bit different than a typical
Python package that you might be
familiar with is that there's parts of
it that maintains state so the
environment objects are one of those the
predictive service objects that I'm
going to show you next is another one
and you want to think about this what we
do is we write something into your home
directory and this is where we sort of
maintain a workbench because you don't
want to have to type this in every time
you don't want to have you just want to
be able to refer to your ec2 environment
logically and the same with something
that you're doing in ec2 like you create
a predictive service deployment which is
a cluster of machines that's always on
so you don't want to have to remember
the code to load it over and over again
you should just be able to squirrel that
away and then load it back and that's
what the the graphlab dot deployed out
environments or predictive services
objects will show you so so far so good
we've just set up this metadata object
about how we want to use ec2 so the next
step is to actually launch the cluster
so that's what this code does so I'll go
through this API it's one API call
GraphLab deploy dot predictive service
dot create we're gonna give it a logical
name
Yelp funny and logical name means this
is how it's going to be stored on my in
my home directory on my laptop so that I
can logically refer to this cluster I
can close my laptop go home
open it later and logically load up the
cluster if I want to look at it then I
want to pass in the ec2 environment this
is the configuration for ec2 that I want
to use so that's this object that we
instantiated earlier and then where do I
want to keep this this last line is
really important for predictive services
it's a cluster of machines so we want to
keep all the metadata about that cluster
not trapped on my laptop but someplace
in s3 this way if my laptop gets run
over by a bus I haven't lost all
pointers to my cluster I can still go
and load that from another machine and
the other reason this is important is
this is the standard sort of this the
best practice for how teams work
together with one cluster one person
sets up the cluster and then all they
have to share is this path and then
email that to the other team member the
other team member can then load that
predictive service assuming you guys
have credentials that all fall into one
parent account or you get you guys share
credentials however you want to do that
as long as you can access that location
in s3 you can then load the predictive
service to take administrative actions
on it like deploying a new model to it
scaling it up from one two nodes three
nodes to eight nodes or shutting it down
obviously there's other operations but
you get the gist does this make sense
it's one line to launch a cluster now if
we actually waited for that to happen it
would take like 15 minutes so I'm just
gonna do what I just described where I'm
going to load an existing deployment so
this is one of our demo clusters so it's
one command G L dot deployed a
predictive service dot load notice how
this one's not create this one's dot
load and I'm just passing in this one
path an s3 which is where the the state
of that predictive service is captured
and then I'm going to print it out so
that you can see so what you guys see
here is this is the the logical name for
this predictive service it's called demo
lab - psych it this is the path that we
just used the state path there's no
description because I didn't feel like
writing one this is the API key this is
an important important key that this is
what you need to make any queries
against this predictive service so it's
not open
to the world you've got to pass the API
quien when an application is querying it
there's also an authentication key which
we don't visibly show but is also
configurable and that that is how you
need an authentication key in order to
make administrative changes like so
actually sorry it's called an admin key
API key is for requests admin key is for
doing things like add a node remove a
node from the cluster so administrative
operations are with one key and data
plane or query operations requests are
using a different key both of these are
configurable for this demo I've I'm not
using SSL but you can obviously set up
an SSL certificate and make sure all
your traffic is over SSL as well so far
so good since this is running over
normal HTTP I'm not setting a course
origin I'm not querying it using
JavaScript where I want to set up which
domains but you can do all of that as
well and I'll go into this in more
detail tomorrow but there's a
distributed caching layer built into
predictive services what you can see is
this is the load balancer name so like
all good distributed systems there's a
load balancer to make sure we shed we
share the load when we send requests and
you can see what models or predictive
objects have been deployed we didn't
want to call them just models because
like like what we did in this example we
defined a function that wraps a model
and does a few other things to it this
funny predictor so this isn't really
just a model this is a predictive
objects that's why we named it that it's
a little confusing you'll see I use them
interchangeably but you see that I've
already got one deployed named funny and
it's at version 5 and caching is enabled
for it if you want to see all of the
predictive services I have on my machine
yeah it's the same as the environments
it's just predictive services you can
see I have a handful of them all right
so if you guys are following along and I
hope you all are cuz this is super
exciting by now
the AWS cluster has probably launched so
you want to add a model because you
wouldn't have one in this cluster
already this deployment wouldn't have
the the predictive object at all but in
our case we already have a
predictive object named funny and so I
want to update it so this is a really
important piece so one of the the
powerful things you can do with
predictive services is support your your
iterative development and or iterative
deployment scenarios so you don't want
to you want to update an existing model
say you're training a new model on a
nightly basis you want to update that
model in production after you've
finished your validation testing or
after you've gone through your your
testing of that trained model so we want
to do update so what we've done is we've
staged this change we haven't actually
deployed the change yet and this is
important we're dealing with production
here so we don't want to just randomly
start changing production so we make you
go through two steps this also allows
you to stage many model changes at once
and then apply them so when I run this
deployment dot apply changes this is the
first time that the model that we
trained in this ipython notebook that's
on my laptop is getting deployed
someplace else
so because we have great Wi-Fi here
we're already done so we took this model
that was trained locally and we pushed
it to s3 and what you can see is we
pushed it to the same to the to the path
that we defined using that s3 state path
so that took us to that path goes to
there and then we put all our predictive
objects under it with their version
numbers so you know you can immediately
tell how you get back to a previous
version if you want to roll back roll
forward so you have all the the model
management steps handled for you once we
uploaded it we notified each of the
nodes in this cluster in this deployment
that hey there's a new model go with
zero downtime rollover and pick up the
new model and start serving it
so now let's query it we have this model
deployed now let's go and actually find
out if it's any if we send it a review
if it does a decent job of classifying
that review as funny or not so I can get
to this deployment just by using that
same indexing scheme for the predictive
services so let's do that
you guys should should get ready if you
look ahead from the audience I'm gonna
ask you guys to give me a review to put
in so let's try a couple examples here
so
I'm using a Python client library but
you don't have to use a Python client we
have one built-in but this is just a
REST API so you can use whatever client
library you'd like it's really really
easy to wrap curl with and curl there's
a lib curl in every programming language
I shouldn't say that in most programming
languages and and then you can use that
really easily to query this REST API but
because we're in Python I thought I'd
show you built using the built in Python
client library that we have so we're
gonna query this funny predictive object
and what this really is doing is
querying this rest endpoint with this
name so this is the service endpoint for
for this object with the text of
Keisha's bad so what you guys think is
this gonna be funny or not not funny all
right so we ran it what you see happens
is we connect it to the load balancer
just like we should and we got back a
response and whoever said that who
sounded half-asleep was right oh you
okay you're oh okay you're just talking
into your hand that's all I see
so you were right funny is no nut
doesn't predict that but it's not super
confident in that prediction because the
probability is only 52% notice something
else guys we deployed version 5 or
version 6 right you guys paying a lot
and paying attention but we saw that we
got version 5 well that's not right
but that's because of caching so we
already had a cache result because I of
course ran my demo like half an hour ago
to make sure it was working before I got
on stage so let's do it again really
fast
aha so this is a this is another
important thing that we offer at
predictive services we proactively warm
the cache so now I queried again this
time I got my response from the version
6 from version 6 of the model but you
saw it didn't take any time and that's
because when we made the request just a
minute ago the we returned the stale
version 5 response but recognized it was
stale and went and asked the engine to
give us the correct answer and and
proactively put that into the cache so
this way you don't see a latency spike
where
the hot keys in your cache while when
you do a model update and we do this for
15 minutes every time you do a model
update and then after that the the TTL
on the keys is expired and then we will
go back and get the correct answer from
the new model but this is a way that you
don't have to worry about seeing latency
spikes during when you deploy a new
model so let's try this other one what
do you guys think damn this is good
funny or not funny cause it got
swearword in it all right let's find out
you are correct this the classifier
believes this is funny also cached let's
try it again now we're getting the the
correct answer it's the same answer
because we didn't change the model but
it's the from the right version how
about this last one damn [ __ ] it's kind
of fun to say that into a mic funny or
not funny you are correct
with pretty high probability at 69% all
right guys it's your turn
what's the review text it is blank
intentionally blank this space
intentionally left blank not funny I am
sorry the classifier disagrees how about
a couple more sure Amazon reviews would
be interesting but this is a Yelp data
set so restaurant reviews but it's say
it again the real what don't eat quiche
ah real programmers don't eat oh I got a
backspace this don't eat quiche I get
that right funny yes all right
it's not super confident in that how
about one more oh there we go
I put an exclamation point myself but
didn't help still not funny
but this is really you know this is a
sort of a toy example but you can see
the power of how easy it is to integrate
your model into into a bigger
application because it's just a rest
endpoint and you and every application
can interact with a rest endpoint so
let's do one from-from curl just so you
guys believe me that I'm not there there
is no special python going on here so
I'm making a curl request it's a post
and then this is the the payload of the
post the API key that you saw earlier
the the text is the data JSON object and
then the URL you're going to this is the
load balancer slash data slash
that we gave for this for this endpoint
so the outputs not quite as well
formatted but you can see the exact same
thing damn this is good
is funny now I'm gonna end with showing
you what the visualization in graphlab
canvas which you Chang showed you
briefly looks like and I have to zoom
out a little bit actually maybe not that
far so what you can see is we have our
three node cluster it's the same
information that we saw from the command
line but it's a little nicer to look at
we also submit metrics to AWS and you
can - cloud watch so you can set up
alarms and do all the operational things
you'd like to do that's it guys how am i
doing on time good uh-oh what have I
done how do I get out of fullscreen
oh I click on this thing so I've left
you guys with a couple links to some
more information but let's go back I
don't have any closing slides this is
the end so once again you can come in
here more about deploying models to
production tomorrow in the afternoon and
you can hear more about the the
underpinnings of the s frame that you
chang introduced today on sunday and you
check and i are around to help answer
any other questions you guys have and
get you unblocked hopefully this was a
fun tutorial all right thank you
you